you saw you don't know me no for eight
seasons LL Cool J has started the CBS
show NCIS Los Angeles as Special Agent
Sam Hanna here's a preview of Sunday's
episode looks like he was getting rid of
evidence
evidence of what gold heist alright so
the bike comes down here they fire at
him he takes them out second bike comes
from behind catches him by surprise
I hit
maybe hello Cool J we welcome you back
to the table so that is Sunday's episode
but I hear the word on the street is
about the finale it's the most dramatic
thing that's ever been done on TV it is
you know Sam Hanna my character his wife
gets kidnapped and then all hell breaks
loose and you know for procedural I
think Scott gamble the new showrunner
really took the character development
and the whole idea of really getting
into the stories and the personalities
of these characters to another level on
the owner but it does sound like hype to
say the most dramatic ever done yeah you
know people always say that but this
time it is actually true you know you're
not her rescue um yeah it is somebody
died is this about a rescue exactly um
yes somebody uh a cast member does get
oh not more rather they get oh yeah I
get a water guillotine nothing happens
to my brother to the old model well you
got to watch and see but it's a little
more dramatic than you probably expect I
promise you that let's talk about you
because you play Sam Hanna yes former
Navy SEAL he speaks so many languages
yes you have anything in common with him
in real life um I could speak a few
languages but I think that in general
this guy is much more heroic than I ever
be I mean he puts his life on the line
every day I don't it takes a lot of
courage heroism well I've had my moments
yes yeah yeah what are you talking about
in between passing the great point
somebody broke into and you kicked butt
please there do anything shawl you
wouldn't do that you've also used this
show since Sam Hanna is a former Navy
SEAL to dress veterans issues and the
challenges that veterans have had in
seeking care well you know I I haven't
personally done that but I guess you
know when you think about it my father
was in the Navy my grandfather was in
the Army I do think veterans to get
taken care yeah you know I also should
think they should be put in harm's way
for the right reasons another world
reasons do you know that's there's a
whole big conversation there Todd dave
grohl was here yesterday and he said
that every musician has a musical
epiphany where the music becomes more
than just sound to them what was your
musical epiphany that everybody has it
it's an interesting thing I think for me
um I was walking down I was in junior
high school
and I was walking down the hallway and
uh you know it was like kind of dimly
lit hallway because of just where was
that in the building I saw this kid he
was from behind saying this DJ gets down
mixing records where they go around and
I was looking at him from the back and
it was like it it was like a cloud was
around it was like I want to do that
yeah yeah that was it that was the
moment for me as your yushik taken a
second yeah second place to your acting
well you know my love for music hasn't
taken second place but in terms of just
my logistical priorities I'm you know
I'm working on TV and I'm focused on
television right now yeah but I mean I
you know I'd love to go out and perform
I still do festivals I still do concerts
you know people can you know log on to
my website and check out what I'm doing
next and uh hit me up on Instagram
available at hook shows and things like
that huh you're available to host shows
and thankfully I mean you know if it's
right you know I'm not going you know
host the opening of an envelope you know
the same but if it's right you know if
it's right I'll go bro yeah I'll be
there
no listen Nora I went to hug him
backstage yeah and I did this Sam for a
second okay Nora please no I gave him I
know this is not appropriate but please
know your gut are you going to work out
oh Jesus touch that Island yeah I've
already touched him bow okay okay ladies
lady don't you claim victory you're the
old can it was touching okay no no I
felt I went Lord let me sit down and
take that in force I am furious about
your workout routine mom I hit the gym
really hard to work out four five times
a week I do boxing and I do weights I do
a combination lifting little children
yeah well three weights yeah in a
metaphorical sense I guess free weights
free weights definitely free weights and
machines weights yeah and a lot of
cardio could be you stamina you look
good thank you appreciate I asked ere is
the Sundays at 8 7 central right here on
CBS